(upbeat electronic music)
- Imagine two acres of land
that are covered with Las Vegas history,
dating from the 1930s up to present day,
and when you walk in, they tell a story.
The Neon Museum was founded
in 1996, and we rescue signs.
There are over 200 signs
in the Neon boneyard.
Las Vegas is a town that
is known for imploding
all of its hotels and not
preserving its history
because we're always wanting to move on
to the bigger, better, brighter thing.
There's beauty in the worn signs.
They're a glimpse into the past.
You see that rusted paint.
You see the broken neon, and
it's kind of bittersweet.
The folks who designed these
are really master craftsmen.
They hand-blowed the neon that's in them.
The Yucca Motel, the intricate
artwork, the glass blowing
that had to go into the
design of the actual Yucca,
the Stardust spire
reaching up into the sky.
It's becoming a art
form that's going away.
We preserve a lot of those memories
so people who didn't see the
signs actually on the strip
are able to come here and get a real sense
for what they were like in person.